optimal room at this altitude I can run
flat out for a half mile before my hands
start shaking so now I also know I'm a
cybernetic organism living to show our
medical facility this episode is brought
to you by me undies which I'm wearing
right now
I've spent the last year or so wearing
underwear from these guys nearly 24/7
except when I'm having fancy to them and
they are the most comfortable and
colorful underwear I have ever owned if
you can imagine really awesome graffiti
that you've seen in cities like LA or
elsewhere then turn into a print and put
onto underwear you get the idea
there's also some weird stuff like
Halloween themed camo which I have for
myself me Andy's designed in LA and made
from sustainably sourced micro mowed ow
why is this important it's three times
softer than cotton and you feel that
difference on your loins ladies and
gentlemen if they feel good on it and if
you don't love your first pair of me
undies they'll hook you up with a new
pair or a refund what kind of person
sends in used underwear back to someone
I don't know that makes you a strange
person maybe you should sell them in
Japan or something but if you love the
product and they make a great gift also
and for those people wondering I go
boxer-briefs if you love it they have a
subscription offer or you can save up to
33% after your first pair so check it
out me undies dot-com forward slash Tim
you can see some of my favorite
underwear and also planning for the
ladies that's me undies comm forward
slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by
headspace the world's most popular
meditation app I have it on my phone I
use it all the time when I'm in ubers
when I'm in airplanes when I'm in those
in-between spaces and I want to do some
good for myself across all of the guests
that I've had on this podcast more than
eighty percent have the common behavior
at the common habit of some type of
meditative practice it does not have to
be complicated or expensive headspace is
meditation made simple I've used it for
hundreds of sessions myself it provides
guided meditations you can use whenever
you want wherever you want whether on
your phone computer or tablet they have
sessions that focus on everything from
decreasing stress and anxiety to eating
healthier sleeping better and even being
more creative but I suggest you keep it
simple simple simple this is a huge
impact in my life try there take ten
program it is fantastic ten minutes of
guided meditation today for 10 days it
costs you nothing
try it out and I promise and I don't do
this very much that you will see a
significant benefit from it download the
headspace app and train your mind for a
happier healthier life learn more at
headspace calm forward-slash Tim that's
headspace calm forward-slash Tim I'm
being watched right now this is Tim
Ferriss welcome to another episode of
the Tim Ferriss show I'm going to
whisper right now and just assume that
all of you have ASMR fetish or a
preference and if you don't know what
ASMR is you should look it up there's a
huge community on reddit for instance
pins for autonomous sensory meridian
response and that's why I'm also going
to bite this piece of shortbread right
now I'm whispering because I'm in the
Lufthansa lounge at JFK that one's free
Lufthansa call me and I can't be my
usual boisterous self but as per always
one tip airshows my job to deconstruct
world-class performers people who are
very good at what they do people have
interesting stories and very specific
tactic two recommendations that you can
implement in your life to reduce a shore
and my guest today it's very appropriate
that I should be in the airport because
he travels more than any human being I
have ever met
seen videos of him shaving in Airport
and airplane bathroom curtains Phil
Keoghan that's Keo gh a.m. you can say
hello on the Twitter's that's Phil
Keoghan has worked in television for
almost 30 years on more than a thousand
program episodes in more than a hundred
countries his work has earned him
numerous awards including ten Primetime
Emmy Awards is perhaps best known as the
Kazakh and producer and host of the
perennial favorite CBS series The
Amazing Race currently in its 29th
season but there's a lot more to Phil
story and then you might know of or
expect including unbelievable bucket
lists and how important they are to how
his life has been run and improved and
many of the decisions that he's made a
near-death experience probably more than
one and much more he is very good at
proactively creating adventures for
himself and is also very impressive
athlete on multiple levels for instance
in 2013 he decided to retrace the 1928
Tour de Falls riding an original vintage
bicycle with no gears ways of bouts
where I'd say at least twice as much as
modern bikes to tell the forgotten
underdog story of the first
english-speaking team to take on the
toughest sporting event on earth he
captured this entire experience and
turned it into a brand new film
documentary called the ride LD space RI
d a gorgeous dock and the first to be
shot on a Sony f55 camera in 4k which is
the equivalent of super 35 millimeter
film and you can check that out at Phil
Keoghan Laroy comm and we will talk a
lot more about that but there were many
things take away from this conversation
and I hope you do it as much as I did so
as I always say without further ado here
is Phil Keoghan
so welcome the show thank you for having
me I am excited to have you here in
Austin Rainey Austin Rainey Austin sit
across the table yeah and to talk about
your life and experiences I don't even
know where to start and there are a few
options I think I'm going to go with
humor first okay and I was hoping you
could tell us a little bit and then
we'll spread out in both directions
chronologically about Milli Vanilli Oh
dreadlock twirling oh yeah yeah Milli
Vanilli so I started in television when
I was really young like eighteen and I
really wanted to be a cinematographer
and makes you know tell stories with a
camera being television
I was not popular with my family for
making that choice because I wanted to
go straight out of high school into
working in television and there was no
there were no degrees you could get in
broadcasting or communications degrees
and so against my family's better wishes
I went and took this job it was hard to
get where I was a television assistant
and and then miraculously that led from
me being a camera assistant to then
being in front of a camera and I guess I
was 20 and I was working on a daily live
show was called 3:45 5:00 that's how the
thing went 3:45 because it was on at
3:45 and it was live and so anybody who
was anybody who came to New Zealand came
on this show 3:45 live Monday to Friday
and so milli vanilli make their way to
New Zealand and this is when they were
like they'd won the Grammy for Best New
Artist there were those songs you know
those great songs blame it on the rain
I'm trying to think of what the other
songs were but anyway um they came in
and a beautifully dressed and then like
like look like models male models the
dreads whirl beautifully keptin and they
wouldn't sit down on the chair and then
the manager was talking to them and
there was no sort of like lead-up to the
to the chat they just sort of LaRon to
one side talking amongst themselves and
then we were about to go 3:45 live and
then they sat down at the last minute
and we're on the show live and why
didn't they sit down they didn't want to
crease their pants what is what I
suspected because the pants had these
beautiful creases in them and like I
said there were like beautifully dress a
lot of attention to detail and um so
they they finally sat down and then in
the middle of the interview I'm looking
across I think it was at Fabrice because
it was Robin Fabrice and I noticed that
the dreadlock is detached from his head
while he's twirling it and in him and I
was like ah like I I'm figuring that you
know this is I'm looking to see what
whether it was noticeable on the monitor
and then I sort of turn around and I see
behind me the manager is like gesturing
to them to tell them that the dreadlock
had become detached now I mean I should
have just gone with it but I don't think
they really had a sense of humor I don't
think that would have thought that was
funny they were way too concerned with
how they look it would have been very
off-putting how many segments if you had
to guess in total do you think you've
done of television of any show it
possible - I don't know hundreds
thousands thousands yeah I mean I I'm
going to be 50 this year I started in
front of a camera in nineteen so what is
that 31 years I don't know I don't know
I did a lot of live television so I did
this show 345 live for a year so there
was two hundred and something live shows
and then I did a daily live show called
breakfast time in the early 90s Tom
Bergeron was the host and then there
were a number of us who were out on the
road doing basically anything we wanted
to do they gave us a satellite truck a
camera operator and a production
assistant and we could go anywhere in
America to do five stories from anywhere
in America and we would go every day
live and we'd have to do two stories
from that place live and everything from
hand feeding sharks live to changing a
lightbulb delivers an abridged live to
milking spiders to being in
coal mine or whatever it was and so that
was over the period of four and a bit
years that would being close to 800
shows and how old were you at the time
when he did that that was I was 24 I
think some 24 25 so before we go into
the near future oh yeah from Millie
earlier I like half my life I think
that's right yeah in the in the grand
scheme of the universe the blinking of a
firefly back to age 19 right and you had
an experience that it seems has framed a
lot of what came afterward and I was
hoping you could describe what happened
yeah so when you're 19 most 19 year olds
I don't think they're going to die I
certainly didn't think I was going to
die I was invincible we used to do
ridiculous things think that we were
somehow protected by the speed gods or
whatever it was and so we did things
that we probably shouldn't have done and
now I think looking back on it I just
lucky to have got to this point in my
life I think but you know we like
putting ski bindings and skis and
strapping into a roof rack of a car and
then going into a tuck and seeing how
fast we could drive the car and you know
as fast as we possibly could anyway I I
was doing a story about a 22 thousand
ton shipwreck that had sunk in in New
Zealand and it was down about 120 feet
underwater and it was on its starboard
side 22,000 tons is like it's as big as
you know a cruise liner that you see
going around at the ports around the
world and big really big and 120 feet is
for people who've never done any scuba
diving unless you have special equipment
I mean that's not a lot of bottom time
exactly so most recreational divers get
certified to dive to about 60 feet the
best stuff that you see underwater is
generally in the first 30 feet because
once you get past 30 feet the color
changes you you lose all the reds and
everything becomes very blue
so I always say to people look you don't
need to go deep unless you're going on
to a wreck or something some real reason
to go deep
the only reason to go deeper you know if
it is a wreck you can get great diving
in 10-15 feet of water
with the car will close to the surface
the colors are brighter and so on but
this wreck was deep and and and as you
said the deeper you are the faster you
chew through air and you eat up air and
that affects how long you can stay down
and the longer you're down deep the more
nitrogen you get in your blood and so
it's it is a real science to diving in
you have to be super careful as you're a
diver I am yeah so you understand same
people get nitrogen narcosis yeah
exactly hundred twenty feet so I guys
start to tried to take off all of his
gear and just drop it in a small group
and he was stopped but I was the guys
man that worked at Chippendales I know
they know it was a different guy
different guy okay no but I put people
yeah I've seen the same thing to take
the regulator out and they start having
conversations with fish it's not a good
idea
no getting NART yeah yeah so that's all
the more reason to get properly
certified so I was with some very
experienced divers and way more
experienced than me and they were they
were doing this salvage and we were
going to be the first people to shoot on
the ship get to go inside the ship and
explore it and the the cameraman that I
was with was also very experienced but
because there was because there's so
much silt inside the boat and there was
a current as well rolling through the
boat we were we and we in those days we
were shooting on film it's not like
today where you could go down with a
great GoPro and some lights and you know
you could film for a couple of hours we
had a two and a half minute roll of film
in a 100 foot daylight spool roll that
was in a little housing inside the case
so literally that's the only amount of
footage we had to shoot on film that's
how long I go back so that the plan was
that we would go into the ballroom of
the of this ship and big big boulder
room and then the crew would come in
from another door and we would meet in
the middle so that we didn't stir up all
the silt going into the same entrances
we'd swim
towards each other that get us coming
towards them and so we go down and what
I know now is if you go into a wreck you
tie a line on the outside of the wreck
so that you have something to follow out
if something goes wrong these guys were
so familiar with the wreck and so
experienced and knew the place so well
they didn't tie a line on and I just
sort of followed them in not knowing
that that was sort of what you should do
and you know the other rule with diving
is you never leave your dive buddy so
I'm following this guy and I was too
scared to tell him because I was trying
to be a man that before that I was
really claustrophobic so I go in this
little doorway and it would have been
like let's imagine a small window like
two by three we go through this little
porthole and then we start weaving our
way through the ship and I as we going
deeper and deeper and deeper into the
shipwreck I'm completely disoriented it
I had no idea where I am from my hand
sweats just listening to the description
oh yeah and I started to breathe like
breathe but every time I sort of like
was at the point of tapping into go you
know I got to get out of here I feel
panicky he just kept disappearing deeper
and deeper and deeper in another corner
another corner I thought and he was
moving quickly because he's used to
being in this wreck they're doing the
salvage on this thing
so finally we we come into an opening
and then he shines the light around and
there's this huge bull room now the ship
is on its starboard side on its right
side so all the tables on a ship are all
bolted to the floor so imagine the
tables on a right angle to us and then
he gestures to me to hold on to the
table and then he told me on the surface
that he we were going to switch out the
lights to save battery power because
it's cold and now we don't have a lot of
we've got seven mill wetsuits on is
pretty cold and you can feel kind of the
current pushing through the ship and
that's why we were holding on to the
table so we didn't drift in you know
through the room and now we're looking
ahead and he sort of points at me and
looks ahead and says that's where the
crew is going to come out and I knew
that that's where they're going to come
out so I was like okay so we're waiting
with the lights off in the dark and I'm
processing all of this and
starting to try to slow my breathing
down like stay calm it's okay you know
you're with an expert everything is good
and after what seemed like like minutes
all I wanted to turn my light on but I
also didn't want to do it cuz I thought
he'll think I'm a wimp like why my turn
well I just wanted to turn my light on
to see where I was like they have sent
some sense of where I was he flicks his
light on like in Halloween when you take
your life and put it at the chins and
you make yourself look scary right
that's all I remember the light went on
it's he's pointed from his chin looking
up he looks scary
then he gestures me with his hand puts
it out in front of me like wait then he
points at my hands on the table like and
gestures for me to hold on to the table
and then boom he just disappears around
a corner and I don't have my light on
he's got his light on it and the light
disappears and he's gone well in that
moment I'm like why is he leaving why
did he just leave so in my haste to find
my light too I'd start flailing around
let go of the table and I feel myself
drifting away from where the table is
and moving drifting into the ballroom
and I just went into a mad panic and I
couldn't find my light by the time I
found my light Ida silted up all the
water around me I couldn't see anything
and now I don't know where the table was
that I was meant to hold on to and I'm
looking ahead I can't see any lights I
can't see him and I started to breathe
really really fast and now you're a
diver you understand this but when you
dive and for anybody who's never had a
regulator in their mouth if you breathe
too quickly there's a little diaphragm
that allows for exhalation and
inhalation in the in the regulator that
you put in your mouth to suck in air if
you go too fast the diaphragm can't keep
up with the speed of inhalation and
exhalation and then you start to suck
order them so I started like taking a
little bits of water and I'm being the
the valve and just panicking like mad
mad panic and I thought I have to get
out of here
and well you all you want to do is just
get out right but I don't know how to
get out I don't know where up and down
is I don't the bubbles don't go up when
the ships on its side like that and you
deep down they
the walls and then they run up the walls
they follow weird pass and I thought I
have no idea where I am
right now I can't even see where the
table is and panicking panicking and I
knew that someone had died in there
someone had gone in there and got
disconnected from a group and he had
died and drifted off into the ship and
died I also knew that one of the
engineers never made it out when the
ship sank in the first place and just to
set the stage also for people listening
I remember when I did a dive at the Blue
Hole in Belize which is about 120 feet
this is when this guy got narked it
takes so long to get down because you're
equalizing yeah by the time you get down
at least we were told at the time with
the gear we had you have eight minutes
yeah so all of this is happening yeah
very quickly very quickly very quickly
and we we weren't on nitrox night rocks
as you know is a is a is a mixed gas
that you can get where it has more
oxygen and less nitrogen so it increases
your bottom time so this is pre nitrox
days and so yes you're absolutely right
we had a very limited window which is
why he must have gone off to find the
crew because he realized we are eating
up a lot of time and where were they
we're with a crew well I don't remember
exactly how I got from there to the boat
but this guy obviously came back to get
me and really it's all a blur between
panicking mad panic eyes like wide like
sources to being on the boat to looking
up into the sky and seeing the most
amazing blue I'd ever seen in my life
like just look like totally surreal and
then and I'm lying on the ground like
breathing and I look up and all these
faces looking down at Phil you're good
you're good I'm like yeah yeah I'm good
I'm good like trying to play like
nothing happened
but my heart is pounding like pounding
and I was so like the feeling the
feeling of euphoria the the relief of
being alive to know that I was alive was
was like nothing I'd ever experienced
and it really was all this stuff
It was as if my IQ went up 25 points in
that moment you know what I mean because
I was like how dumb will you that I
thought you were going to live forever
how dumb were you that you did you've
been doing all these dumb things in your
life and you have real really have no
purpose in life and I started to think
about this is all happening while I'm
having these conversations on but I'm
like I'm thinking man I I love girls and
I haven't even like really explored that
whole world and that's like the second
or third that comes up it was actually
tried out there's no powers obvious my
sexual prime I mean come on everything's
right out there I don't want to say it
was the first thing because I don't want
you to get the wrong idea about it but
it was up there and I was like damn you
know you've got a lot to do with your
life so no but there were all these
things that came to me and a lot of them
were very selfish I was 19 years old so
I got myself together and I I wanted to
find a piece of paper and a pen and I
just wrote down just everything that I
felt like I had all the time in the
world to do and that I had to get down
on a piece of paper to get out to go
okay this is not a dress rehearsal you
can die you will die you don't know how
long you've got before you die you
better figure out what you're doing with
your life and you better get on with it
straight away
and one of the first things on my list
was go back in the shipwreck seriously
because I thought I cannot walk away
from this fear I was so petrified of
what had happened and I and I decided I
would explain to the diver you know that
I found it challenging
he knew that challenging but I said it's
like kind of like falling off a horse I
really felt like gotta get back on gotta
get back on I have to go back because if
I let this fear get on top I'm with some
string or so well I didn't actually go
back with Jim because I didn't even I
didn't I didn't have time to do the
lesson about this string yeah but I but
I went back with by disclosing a little
more of my fear to the other diver and
was more honest
and and then he when he knew that and we
had to get this thing shot he was
obviously more aware of you know he
thought I was so because I was so
gung-ho like he didn't have any
indication that there was any fear in me
at all but then I kind of said you know
listen to man I really forgot he goes oh
no kidding and I and I said but I need
to go back we've got to go back and do
this and we went back and we did it and
we shot it and that was the start that
was the first thing I take off my list
question for you so when you decided to
go back down yeah as your descent or
petrified and getting ready to go
through that tiny opening yeah
what was the self-talk I mean it's a
long time ago but what what is your
self-talk like in a moment like that
well it's something that I've used a lot
since then which was instead of
internalizing everything I looked out
and what I realized was that this guy
was super experienced and had been down
on that shipwreck many times and come
out of there successfully many times and
if I followed his procedure and if I
observed him being an expert doing
something and looked out at that rather
than turning it back into my own head
about what I didn't know and what I
couldn't do that
I was in good hands so ever since that
moment and all the crazy things that
I've done I've taken a tremendous amount
of comfort in being surrounded by people
who I know are better at me at doing
something who have tremendous expertise
at whatever they're doing and to really
observe them in that moment when they
are in there when they are using
expertise than they're ultimately they
have take that is taken possibly at
least 10,000 hours to get to and and to
look at it in a way like wow how cool is
that I'm with this person then or woman
whoever it is that is allowing me and
giving me the privilege to be with them
to do what they do so well and they are
specialists and they're so good and so
you would be explicitly reminding
yourself of all these things if you're
going into a situation that is
provoking nerves and fear is that yeah
the voice inside the head it is its I
made up a quote which I really that I
share with a lot of people which is
focus on what you do have and what you
can do instead of what you don't have
and what you can't do and I really am a
big believer in practicing to change
mindset so my daughter who's 21 I say to
her Elle you're young you have this
amazing pliable brain I said if you
practice being an optimist now at this
young age by the time you're my age with
thousand hours of practicing being an
optimist you're going to be an amazing
optimist if you practice focusing on
what you do have and what you can do as
opposed to what you don't have and what
you can do you're going to be so good at
using what's around you and focusing on
what you can do with it that the
negative stuff will be there but you're
it's going to be squashed by this
positive energy that you have and I said
what the last thing you want to do is
get to my age and be somebody who is so
practiced at making excuses and so
practiced at being a pessimist that it's
hard to make a turn you don't want to be
50 trying to make a turn being an expert
as a pessimist and we've all met them
sure and you meet a pessimist or or a
game of somebody who's great excuses
sometimes I will hear excuses and I will
laugh out loud and the person will look
at me like what are you laughing at I'm
like dude you are unbelievably good at
excuses this is like expert black belt
you are you are a black belt in excuses
and and so and I never think it's too
late to change I'm just saying that it's
harder to change because I really
believe like the mind is like a sponge
and it's harder and harder to keep that
sponge moist as you get older right but
I really started to practice that so I
rely on my life I've tried to put myself
around people and I've gravitated
towards people who see that things are
possible and that things that that
anything is possible and to me it's like
magic I feel like I'm around you just
you know magicians who who make things
happen out of nothing and I feel very
honored that with all the stuff that
I've done in my life I've met so many of
these people so I want to talk about
optimism and learning or teaching
optimism because what you were just
saying reminded me of a conversation I
had with a close friend of mine he's not
not much older but a bit older he is a
number of kids and I asked him when we
were hiking once
what would your advice be to a
first-time parent and he said really
it's only two things and he said number
one your kids don't owe you anything
because you chose to have them yes
number one yeah number two is teach your
kids to be optimists yeah they said if
you teach them to be optimists they can
handle almost everything else it's great
advice by the way and I totally agree
with it
how would you or how do you help to
cultivate optimism in your daughter or
in other people what types of patterns
would you interrupt or what types of
things would you have them do does
anything come to mind yeah I think we're
going to those two points that you
mentioned practice optimism right so one
of the rules that we had in our house
with my daughter is and we all had to
correct each other from time to time we
had this game where nobody was allowed
to say I can't we took I can't out of
the vocabulary in our house and we all
did it but we all got better and better
at not doing it and I wanted my daughter
to practice that and she'd said well dad
there's just certain things I can't do
and I go yeah but you don't want to be
saying we're perpetuating the idea that
you can't do something so find another
way of saying that you find something
challenging or that it's difficult
without saying I can't because we don't
know what we are truly capable of we
have no idea what our full potential is
which is the exciting part of living
right we we have no idea where we're
going to end up or how we're going to
get there so if you take that out and
you say I find this really challenging
is there a way that you can help me do
this you can identify something that you
find really challenging but take that
out of your take I can't out of your
vernacular and you'll be in a much more
positive frame of mind with my daughter
and and and I think with kids when
they're young just allow them to dream
without putting your own limitations on
what it is they think they can do or if
they say they want to do I remember my
daughter came up to me and she was about
nine I I would always read her every
night that was my
I would read some piece of a book to her
so we had that time together any
favorite books do you remember well we
read all of the Harry Potter books
together at every page to her
my daughter's quite a sharp cookie and
sometimes I'd be tired and I'd skip a
few pages but she remembered every
single pages you go dad and I'd go I'd
go was good you skip the part didn't you
like a roll bag to me it was just about
that one-on-one time where you know we
were together and I look forward to it
and the other the other rule I had was
if my daughter ever asked me to do
something no matter what I was doing
no matter even if I was on a deadline if
she said dad can we go play with the dog
kick a football play volleyball will you
read to me that I would always say yes
that was the thing I the rule that I had
which I really valued what would you say
in that case in moments when you are
very very busy guy you have a lot going
on you've done so much let's just say
hypothetically and I'm sure there were
these times that you are under a crunch
deadline there are people maybe
metaphorically yelling and screaming
because they want something by a certain
time then your daughter comes up to you
and asks you for something and I'm not
going to ask this for everything but I'm
very curious what would you say to
yourself or what was the way that you
would ensure that you said yes does that
make sense
aside from practice of course it takes
practice but well I think it's the the
idea that in life life is a series of
moments and what will you remember at
the end of your life you know when you
take your last breath what's the last
thought you're going to have as you die
you know what is that is it some moment
with somebody is it some regret is it
you know you want to die I think in
peace and with something special and so
those moments where where your kid
actually to do something they're limited
when you have them it's a gift right
that the whole idea that you have a
child you never get that back the
deadline thing there many times where I
put what I was doing on hold and spent
the time with her and then it cost me
into the night trying to make up the
time but I can you remember what it was
I was trying to get done but I do
remember the moment
with her right so in the long term those
are the moments that you remember I
couldn't tell you what deadlines I was
rushing to get done that I theoretically
sacrificed to go spend time with my
daughter
so I said a lot of people I was forced
into creating this life list and writing
this book and trying to help other
people with my philosophy of no
opportunity wasted because I had this
experience a lot of people don't have
that experience and I say to them if you
were to take your last breath tomorrow
at 3 o'clock what do you think would be
the last thing in your mind I kind of
get them to just project to that and it
could be something as simple as I always
wanted to write a book I always wanted
to start my own business always wanted
to play the guitar or I always wanted to
spend one-on-one time my dad or I wish
that I'd repaired that relationship with
my brother because we haven't spoken is
that a good way to start such a list I
always wanted to dot dot yeah I really
think when you put something down on
paper sounds so simple it's like a pen
and a piece of paper just write down
something I really believe that it it's
not a small thing that's like almost
like a contract that you've made with
yourself just putting it down the other
thing I say to people is don't just put
it down but write it down and then put
it on a sticky and put it everywhere
where you go where you have like little
moments when you're brushing your teeth
or when you go out to get your keys from
the garage and you put the sticker next
to the keys so things that you places
and Wool spaces that you repeatedly hit
on the refrigerator places that you your
mind goes to every single day around the
house in the car wherever it is little
reminders of well why am I not doing
that so I want to touch on a couple of
things you said the first is a
recommendation for people who are
listening because I had a huge impact on
me which is an article called the
tail-end written by someone named Tim
Urban who has a site called wait but why
which is very intelligently written and
this was recommended to me by friend
Matt Mullenweg has also been on the
podcast and coincidentally he
recommended to me I want to say a few
months before his father unexpectedly
passed away and at the point of the
article and I'm not going to do it
justice everyone should read it was
it it was effectively directed at kids
kids who are now adults and it was an
encouragement to spend more time with
your parents because it said effectively
by the time you leave high school and
leave home to go to college
you've spent say 80% of the total hours
you will ever spend with your parents
before they die now you could look at it
the other way around right as a parent
that by the time your kids leave high
school or leave home you will have spent
or had the opportunity to spend 80
percent of the hours you're ever going
to spend with them together so that
makes perhaps that type of framing makes
it easier to push off the deadlines yes
AK rifice a little bit of sleep so that
that article had and continues to have a
big impact on me that ii was more of a
question i suppose about the i can't and
i really think that our words our
language reflects our thinking yeah in a
very very important way so word choice
obsess over time become more and more
important to me and I've tried to fix
certain tics for instance this is going
somewhere for a long time I realized I
was very lazy with adverbs and I used to
pretty too much oh that's pretty good
that's pretty smart it's pretty
interesting I just it was such a garbage
word that I used as filler so I forced
myself to say [ __ ] after pretty every
time I said it so that's a that's pretty
[ __ ] interesting that's pretty
[ __ ] difficult to pattern interrupt
because I would embarrass myself right
next company and that is how ultimately
ended up stopping using this adverb at
least as much as I used to and I've
tried to help other people who have tics
like arm or like to do something similar
and there are a couple of different
approaches what would you say if you
caught say your daughter
saying I can't was it just would you
just raise a finger or what was the the
button that you push well it got to a
point where she would catch me too
whereas I would say right and so it
would just be ah hell you know it's like
you know we would just call each other
out right which boy that
we were she became hyper aware of it
because we pointed it out to each other
right
and I became hyper aware of the times
that I would sometimes say to funny you
should say about word choices one of the
first shows that I ever worked on was
called that's fairly interesting I
wanted to talk about it oh yeah okay so
this speech to the New Zealand psyche
okay so in America we watch the show in
America called that's incredible well
John that was incredible
right in New Zealand there was a
tendency for high achievers to
understate their achievements you know
okay so we in New Zealand could not have
said that's amazing we had to say in a
New Zealand accent it would be oh yeah
that's fairly interesting and the other
thing we would say is some of New
Zealand New Zealand they could do
something that was groundbreaking but in
New Zealand because it was a New
Zealander who had maybe achieved this
groundbreaking idea we would say oh it's
pretty good oh that's or they take oh
yeah it's pretty good for a New Zealand
er I know it was I was talking I did an
interview with Peter Jackson and he said
the number of times that a studio would
call his agent panicking about something
that Peter Jackson was making because
they'd get on the phone with Peter
Jackson and they'd say to Peter how's it
going you know how's the cut going on
the film and Peter would say oh yeah
that's pretty good come together and
looking pretty good and all the
executives back in LA I start panicking
because there'd be like he sounds less
than enthused this is going to work so
then he'd get off the phone and then his
agent would call and Peter Peter what's
wrong is there a problem with the
production of Peter goes no it's fine
why you guys will they panicking they
didn't think you sounded very excited
about what's going on but that's that's
a huge part of our our psyche is
understating what you're doing now I'd
love for you to elaborate on why that's
the case so one of my closest friends is
a Kiwi and he loves New Zealand but he
has mixed feelings because he talks a
lot about tall
yes could you maybe explain what that is
oh that's one of my favorite topics of
conversation if you imagine a field full
of puppies they're all beautifully
uniformed and all the puppies in the
field they're in you know at the same
exact height and you look at and it's so
comfortable to look at because every
single puppy is within a millimeter of
each other and it just looks so lovely
in uniformed and then you cast your eye
over to the other side of the field and
you see oh my goodness there's a puppy
sticking up and it's taller than all the
other puppies what could that possibly
be
oh that's some guy showing off he thinks
he's better than all the other puppies
in the field and he's sticking up there
showing off well we'll fix that
get a pair of scissors and you cut that
total puppy down and now everything's
beautiful and uniformed again and we
don't have to worry about that tall
poppy do we so it's it's part it's it's
part of our psyche to keep everybody
like the common man so the New Zealand
rugby team they're called the All Blacks
we wear an old black uniform we have a
silver fern on the uniform the most
successful sports team in sports history
and if people haven't seen the haka
correct they need to watch the haka just
google AG just go New Zealand or black
rugby team haka h AKA h AKA it's a Maori
name which is a it's a motive war debt
and they would and and and now a lot of
American football teams have actually
copied as a way of getting psyched up
but when the the indigenous people of
New Zealand the Maori people before
going to war they would get themselves
psyched up doing this haka and they and
it involves a lot of different moves and
slapping themselves and basically
getting themselves hype and ready to go
and now we use it as a way to get hyped
for it before our rugby games and if you
if you see this it's pretty powerful so
the old blacks have a winning percentage
I think of over seventy five percent in
the last 100 years right very rarely do
we do we lose but if you speak to any of
them and they're being the world
champion the only rugby team in the
world
world champions three times only rugby
team in the world to win back-to-back
championships if you talk to an old
block and you go wow you guys are
amazing you get incredible players the
best you're the best and all black or
New Zealander who's a high achiever will
tend to undersell and go odd yeah now
it's really nothing we were just you
know we just went in and did our thing
and yet we just happened to beat the
other team but they played really well
the other team they actually yeah but
you you beat them 85 zero well yeah but
you know we just had a good day and now
you know hats off to the other team and
that's what you do you under self and
then it's it's part of our psyche to be
just like everybody now it's hugely
endearing in one in one way because New
Zealanders and and and I feel like I'm
one of these people where I perform
better when the expectations for me are
lower then when people expect a lot from
me
I don't cope with that very well when
when I have to go do a speech I do a lot
of speeches when everybody's expectation
of my speech is that it's going to be
you know I'm gonna head it out of the
park and it's going to be really great
it makes me nervous because I feel like
okay so you feel like I meant to hit
this mark where do I go from there I
don't know where to go from there
I have to like his out of park twice I
don't know what do I do to get a passing
grade right exactly where as if people's
expectations are oh we think Phil will
do a good job and you know it should be
good if their expectations are there
then I love that space that's left for
me to go punch above that and go hit it
out of the park right because there's
nothing better when you exceed people's
expectations so I think New Zealanders
they always try to underplay where
they're at so that they can exceed
expectations so what you find with a lot
of New Zealand's is incredibly
hard-working they'll tend to undersell
themselves and they tend to surprise
they tend to come out of nowhere and
just like I had no idea you could do
that and so I've just finished working
on a project for the Smithsonian channel
where I talk to a
bunch of New Zealanders about
inventiveness because if there's one
word I would use to describe what Kiwis
are they're incredibly resourceful and
inventive we've invented a lot of
amazing things and we find ways of doing
things in new and different ways because
we're kind of forced to think and and I
love that about our culture but
sometimes when we come to an environment
like in America we're a little reluctant
to put our hand up and go I got this and
other people who sometimes make a lot of
noise maybe don't have the same skills
but they're much better at making a lot
of noise just because this is one of my
favorite topics that's not really topics
isn't the right word for it one of my
favorite things to observe is Kiwis and
Ozzy's going after each other oh yeah
that's just a boy so now what are the
most common go-to insults that authors
use against Kiwis and vice-versa well
all cheap jokes yeah go across the
catchment right a lot of people don't
realize that it's a three-hour flight
between New Zealand and Australia we
have we still have people calling up new
zealand tourism going how longs it take
to drive across the bridge from New
Zealand so stress and you think I'm
joking no no because Sydney and Auckland
both have bridges that look quite
similar and they think that if you drive
over the bridge from Sydney or in
Auckland but that's what's on the other
side so they're like what hold on a sec
makes me feel a lot better about the
u.s. now our three hours what are you
talking about so we're like the little
brother
okay so we're we're four million people
they are 20-something million people
okay
so we've always felt like they're the
Big Brother that wants to beat us up but
we're going to prove ourselves to the
Big Brother so yes any sheep joke we
don't need to go into the details I feel
so in demand oh yeah oh come on this
isn't family programming what's what's
one good one well the one that gets told
a lot is why do I stray Lien's make love
to with their gum boots on so the hind
legs of the sheep can be held in the gum
boots or why do our aliens make love to
sheep on the edge of cliffs
so they'll push back harder I mean
look I mean that's pretty good yeah well
well I mean it's if you need some quick
draw ammo I mean that's that's not a bad
one to have in the pocket but I've been
to rugby matches in Australia where you
stand up in your chair and if there's an
Aussie behind you and they know you're
supporting your black self pour some
beer downsize your chair and it looks
and it's it's a healthy rivalry I think
you know it's just it it's just that the
Australians the Australians to me are
closer to the American culture in terms
of this sports psyche they are really
good at sport you want to talk about
believing in winning Australians really
I think exemplify that New Zealanders I
think less so again I think New
Zealanders they want to come in under
the radar and then exceed expectations
so they don't tend to use the same kind
of psyche up and there's a lot of like
with the cricket matches they call it
sledging you know where the Australian
cricket team are out there on the pitch
in the middle of the pitch and they'll
be going at the you know the opposition
to talk them psych them out basically
they have that edge about them the
Australians do different things to do
more event yeah and they're very
successful by the way I don't like I
mean you look at the number of medals
they win at the Olympics per capita it's
pretty high we're up there as well but
I'm saying the Australians are it's it's
it's a great rivalry let's just say that
and I married an Australian by the way
no I know that's just part of the reason
I brought it up
so the Australians also tend to get well
it depends on how how drunk and sharp
the Kiwis are at the time but a lot of
convict jokes get thrown at the
Australians as well for those people who
want to be amused or completely confused
yes or maybe both bye Kiwis / Australian
humour there's a video that feel like it
was watched by everybody in New Zealand
at one point called Beach days Oh Oh
Beach days proved these days bro has to
do with a whale and I think it's a
seagull among other things you guys can
look that up and chances are you will
not understand what's going on but yeah
but we we have this look I think there's
something like a half a million New
Zealanders living in Australia
like as like a huge portion of Museum of
the New Zealand population live in
Australia I mean because it but now a
lot of Australians if wanted to come to
New Zealand because our economy is doing
ok yeah it is I think it does feel like
a sibling rivalry New Zealand is the
last habitable land mass on earth to be
populated we had we offered a lot of
land incentives to the Irish English and
the Scots a lot of Dutch came over in
the 50s we're very young country like
super young country and in 1880 if I'm
not mistaken the population was
something like 80% men in New Zealand
which is where all that mate ship came
from probably a few sheep jokes as well
but but uh you know we're super super
young country now Australia had a
tremendous number of criminals go there
because England didn't want him you know
as the English voice sullying send them
way down there to that penal colony down
in Australia that'll affect some person
so they they sent them down there there
you know rugged bunch said but don't
ever confuse New Zealanders and
Australians we don't like that yeah we
don't like that looks just like
Canadians a lot of times don't as I was
going to say does one get more offended
than the other because for instance like
if you call an American Canadian really
whatever yeah Canadian get very yeah
general I love you can I Canadian
probably a lot of Canadian friends about
Canadians are more sensitive I think I
think New Zealanders are probably more
sensitive about it I'm I think
Australians are you know they probably
care less than we do so I wanted to ask
you about low expectations versus high
expectations because I remember a friend
of mine navall ravikant once a one
society said if you want to be happy and
I'm paraphrasing here but if you wanted
to be happy spend time people who are
less successful than you if you wanna be
successful spend time with people who
are more successful than you right so
you've spent a lot of time in New
Zealand as well as in the US I remember
at one point when and I'm dubious of how
these things are determined but the the
Danish beat out people in Bhutan and
elsewhere to be voted the happiest
people in the world now John was isn't
it the kingdom of happiness well day of
the gross hat would happiness national
happiness yes which i think is actually
just a
propaganda tool to distract from lack of
GDP among other things but the point I
was going to make is that I asked a
number of my Danish friends about this
and they said in effect it's because we
have such low expectations that's why
we're the actor expectations are so low
now at the same time you've achieved a
lot you've done a lot and you've spent a
lot of time in the u.s. where I would
say a lot of people might argue that
when expectations are higher and people
expect you to do greater things you do
greater things and clearly when I'm
looking at and I'll just read off a few
examples here if we look at some of the
things that you've done
so no opportunity wasted n o W you have
we go on and on I could just spend 20
minutes reading these but pas de Gong do
that I'm not going to do that a
golf-ball across Scotland finishing st.
Andrews complete the Leadville 100
mountain bike race we're going to get to
this in detail but ride the 1928 Tour de
France on a fixed-gear bike correct I
mean they're the same equipment that was
used actually was single speed bike
single speed I'm sorry world record
bungee jump with seven or eight
adventurer crazies it just goes on and
on and on you of this long list and if
you had really really low expectations
could you actually set these types of
goals and achieve them well I've never
it's not that I've ever had low
expectations but this is something I
battled with personally so that's why ya
know I never had low expectations I've
always had this desire to do new and
different if there's one thing that I
would like to be known for it's that I'm
prepared to try something new and
different I like to be surrounded by
people who see again what they do have
and what they can do as opposed to what
they don't have into what they can't do
so nothing drives me crazy er then being
surrounded by people who immediately
start with a wool of no or immediately
start with not having the vision to see
that the impossible can happen and I've
been lucky enough to be around people
who have achieved extraordinary things
and it feeds me you know Malcolm
Gladwell says
anything new and different is most
susceptible to market research and I
really feel that so many people apply
potential and possibility based on what
does it compare to what can we compare
it to will it work there's a fixation on
this idea of failure I find people talk
a lot about things failing in a negative
way I've failed so many times and so
many things but I try not to call them
failures as much as I just call them
giving it a go and if there's one thing
that I have that I love about positive
people is that they are prepared to give
it a go positive people just are
constantly putting themselves out there
to fall on their face and and eventually
they stumble on something that works do
you have any favorite failures that come
to mind and what I mean by that is a
failure that somehow laid the groundwork
for a later success this is any any
particular failure come to mind in your
mind or what other people might consider
a failure that actually was a blessing
in disguise I've tried to put together
you know early on in my career tried to
put together show ideas that I thought
would really work and they just didn't
really work but it was all the
groundwork to be better the next time I
tried to get something to work and I've
been involved with a lot of things that
are pretty mediocre but again I really
do believe in trying and trying and
trying again you know when I was young I
learned how to play the violin when I
was three years old with the Suzuki
method which was rote learning where you
would be in a room with a whole bunch of
people and you play tunes over and over
and over again and then eventually I
could play by ear and when I was seven
or eight my mum's a music teacher I
learned how to read music and I became
quite proficient at playing the violin I
used to go to a music school in New York
I was living in the Caribbean I grew up
in the Caribbean I used to fly from
Antigua and the Caribbean go up to this
music school for up to nine weeks this
was and the travels do to your father's
job yeah my dad my mom um dad traveled
all over the world lived for years in
Canada using the Caribbean we lived in
South America through the Caribbean
lived in Australia and I went to this
school and and and I was probably the
worst musician out of all of these
really talented kids strong enough to
get into
the school but certainly not the best
and I remember being surrounded by this
most extraordinary talent some of the
talent that has gone on to play in the
New York Philharmonic and but a big part
of playing the violin and being
successful particularly at that age was
just practice and practice and practice
I remember how hideous horrible I
sounded you know starting with some new
pieces early on but you'd play and play
over and over and over and over again
you could say that the first
performances that I made were a failure
and then with all of the work and the
effort you end up with something that
sounds halfway decent so I really do
believe in the idea of perseverance and
I feel that a lot of people stopped
short at achieving goals because they're
not prepared to risk failure we analyze
failure particularly as we get older
more and more so I always try to
encourage that with my daughter to
islets say to her give it a go just give
it a go and see what happens you never
know what's going to take you and what
you learn and what you fail that may
help you with something else you know
may not understand how they're related
now but five years from now you're going
to draw on that it's about life
experience and just putting your hand up
and saying I'll give it a go and that's
definitely something that is a New
Zealand trait yeah yeah I'll give it a
go
fake it until you make it I mean that's
a huge part of our psyche like just give
it a go and I mean a lot of people who
have way more talent than me at doing a
lot of things and I'm amazed at how
reluctant they are sometimes to step up
and just and I'll Pat them on the back
over hey you got this dude I'm prepared
to give it a go you're better than me
come on
get up there get amongst it yeah get up
there so I think that comes a lot from
the way that we talk about it in our
culture you know because we celebrate
success but I think we should also just
celebrate people giving it a go give it
a go definitely well I think it's also
depended a lot on where you are even
within say the US yes where say I live
in Silicon Valley I live in San
Francisco where there is very much a
supportive environment for giving it a
go in here to go
yeah and those those people are on the
cutting edge of they like the pioneers
of where we are at right now trying new
and different things you know you the
famous story of the guy who wrote up the
idea for FedEx you know thought he was
crazy new and different right it was
like what do you mean if we're going to
have these central packaging locations
and you're going to fly everything you
like you're flying everything there and
then you fly forever that doesn't make
any sense
yeah I think he failed to yeah yeah you
got I think you got to see or something
I feel like I want to say it was a
business school yeah I still got a
platform gotta get a barely passing
grade or starting along those lines yeah
and so what my frustration is a lot of
people who are in decision-making
positions tend to be the least creative
in the least visionary they're much more
about nuts and bolts and analyzing and
we would not have gone to the moon we
would not have done all the crazy things
that we have done in this world if
people did it based on what we knew at
that time sure we've done all these
extraordinary things because some crazy
people said I'm going to give it a go
and we'll see what happens if your
daughter were putting together her own
no opportunity wasted bucket list mhm
and she said dad I'd love some help how
can I can you help me make this as good
as possible so she already has say 30
things listed and she's I'm worried some
of these things are frivolous I'm not
really sure if they're good items to
have on the list how would you respond
well first of all there are two kinds of
lists I think one is the very personal
list that you have that you might want
to really keep secret because I do
believe sometimes when you put things
out into the university to other people
it can pick up momentum and also I
believe that sometimes if you put
something out there there are negative
energy sometimes with some of the people
that might hear of something you're
trying to do and knock you down because
maybe they have their own frustrations
or they have their own preconceived
ideas about what's possible and they can
put a black cloud over what it is you
want to do but I would say to my
daughter first of all believe anything
is possible and give it a go I remember
when she was nine she said dad I want to
be a professional tennis player wildlife
that and photographer professional
photographer professional photographer
wildlife that and professional
the rational part of my brain is
thinking how's that like if I was giving
advice and she was about to make the
choice that day or if she was working
out how she was going to do it you could
say well that's not really practical
because listen if you want to be a
professional tennis player is going to
take these men this many hours if you
want to be a photographer is going to be
this and if you want to be a wildlife
vetted
making a deliberate effort to say that's
great
we're how you going to do this like I
wanted to understand what was in her
head well I was thinking I could work
like on some kind of research project
and then I could train I could work out
a way to Train and then I could take
photographs while I'm doing my work and
then I could fly to Europe and I could
play you know in the circuit there and
and then that'll keep me really fit and
focused and everything and then I night
I'll work on my photographs and then
I'll go back and take foot like she had
a vision in her head about how she was
who am I to say to her it's not possible
to do all of those things I don't know I
mean I may be she will you know could
have found a way to do that I don't know
so I wanted her to feel at that age yeah
okay go for it give it a go see what
happens you know so you are often
associated you're associated a lot of
things but with the Amazing Race how did
you come to be part of that show it's a
good story I I came to America when I
was 23 24 I thought I wouldn't get
arrested because I had a New Zealand
accent at the time and I was told
nobody wants a New Zealand accent on
television and this is the early 90s and
they weren't wrong because and then a
guy took a chance on me his name was
Jack Sussman who is now at CBS and he
gave he gave me a shot to host a show on
vh1 and that opened the door and then
once I got in because none of my
credentials from before New Zealand
meant anything in America not like today
where you could be a host of Dancing
with the Stars in New Zealand and use
that to leverage getting work here that
they didn't understand what oh what's
this show that's fairly interesting um
but I was exciting it sounds really
exciting I'm in America we go that's
incredible so anyway so
there's a reason for me telling you that
just because he was he later at CBS then
I had this show where that was set up by
an Australian by the name of Peter
Feynman who directed Crocodile Dundee
and he was setting up FX networks and he
took a chance on me to be one of the
field people with that show as telling
you Tom Bergeron hosted and I did that
for four and a half five years so he
took a shot on me because there were
some people like you're going to put a
New Zealand er on the air but anyway
they get gave me a lot of American TV
experience and then we did a show
together on Discovery Channel and I
worked with a cameraman who shot this
adventure series was called Phil Collins
adventure crazy was following my list of
things to do before I die the shuttle
around the world that cameraman was
being considered to shoot Amazing Race
and they looked at his footage and saw
me in his footage and then said who is
that guy and the EIC executive in charge
of production on Amazing Race had worked
with me on that show and he said oh
that's Phil I just was working with him
and I was CBS was aware of me because
I'd been passed over for Survivor was
between Jeff Brooks and I for that job
and a big concern again was that I was a
New Zealander and then finally I
remember I met with Les Moonves and he
said this is the second time your name
has come across my desk in the last I
think we hear he said I'm going to give
you a shot and I remember I got
shortlisted down at 3 then to 2 and then
les had this conversation as movies and
then it just had to good sign up from
Jerry Bruckheimer and Bertram that
monster and released organ Aryan and
Jonathan Lippman and the network and all
the executives were involved in the show
and they said yes and then I had a shot
how many how many shows are how many
episodes have have you done at this
point would you say if you're just
guesstimating I'm guessing it's got to
be 300 and 400 amazing it's a lot it's
29 seasons of 12 and 13 episodes of
season and those 12 or 13 episodes are
each shot in a window of 21 day that's
insane so 12 shows in 21 days that's a
part that a lot of people don't realize
is how intense it is the
just that's just getting the visas alone
for everyone yeah I mean the team that I
work with i lucky to be a part of a
great team and going back to your point
before about working i've been lucky
enough that that's been my experience
throughout my career that I've been
surrounded by people who were better
than me at doing certain things and as a
team member you want to try to match the
level of their input you want to be you
want to be known as a valuable team
player my grandfather always said that
you could bear it build a stereo system
but the stereo system money sounds as
good as the weakest link in the stereo
system same thing I guess with a chain
right it's the same thing and so you
always want to be somebody who is higher
up the chain who is really a strong
element in that team in that framework
but never the never the biggest chain
never the biggest target because but
then you stop then you that's not a good
feeling and I've been oh I've been in
those relations right where you feel
like you're the most experienced in a
team and to be honest with you I don't
really like that I really love looking
across at somebody in a team that I'm on
and going man they are so experienced
and so much better I've been working
with 60-minute sports and working with
the people who produce 60 minutes and
being surrounded by those storytellers
you know fit you feel like you're 18
again and you're starting back at like
ember some advice that I was given quite
a while ago which was if you're the if
you're the smartest person in the room
you're in the wrong room yeah that's a
good one it's a question to you about
hosting what are the most common
mistakes that come to mind that novice
TV hosts make I think where they make it
about them I think the best hosts and
again this is only my opinion the best
hosts are the ones that can facilitate a
conversation with the least number of
words where you've done your research
and and then you basically are letting
them go you let them go and you're
you're there to just keep things moving
and you're there to make them look good
and the better you make them look the
better you are where I get turned off
with some houses where they feel like
they have to one-up the person that
they're meant to be showcase a
showcasing and I see that a lot of times
where and it's finding that balance the
finding the balance of really connecting
with the person but ultimately letting
them be
guests and giving them the last say well
the last word I guess you want to make
them look good you're focused on that
are there any particular hosts or
television personalities that could be
radio doesn't matter you looked at or do
look at as the epitome of that are there
as there's any role models that you grew
up looking towards or even now are you
saying if you had to create so this
Super host you can combine two or three
people do any names come to mind I love
the way Jimmy Fallon plays with his
guests but he's always willing to back
out and let him shine he's really good
at that I just think that takes a real
skill because he himself is so talented
as a performer but he has that ability
to like step back and say you're the
star of my show do you think makes it he
really has a way of having fun and
relaxing and I think he's got so much
better at it too I think when he first
started he was trying to find his way
and now he's sort of hit the sweet spot
what's interesting now is is a lot so
many people watching Colbert because
he's got a much more of a political
message and people are gravitating
towards that more than they are the fun
stuff right easy you can see that in the
ratings I love Jon Stewart's style I
love Colbert style I was a big David
Letterman fan I love Carson I'm
certainly new to podcast so I've been
listening to a lot of different podcasts
I was saying to you before I love that
the piece you did with Adam you know I
like I like that you're so well
researched with your guests and you draw
a stuff out and hit them with things
that they don't necessarily see
something coming because I think
preparation with a good host is so
crucial yeah and okay who else is for a
lot of people in surprising and that's
Howard Stern he has a way of getting
people to open up Howard's a Jedi when I
comes to he's really good and I
personally wasn't surprised because I've
listened to him for a long long time my
favorite part of what he does is talking
to people I love conversations a good
story you could be sitting around a
campfire and if it's a good story it
just works and I think that's the real
measure of somebody who is a good host
so let's talk about stories for a second
are there any particular books besides
besides your own that you would that
you've gifted to people or that you
recommend a lot to other people yeah
every year I read the old man in the sea
and Hemingway a great book it's so easy
to read and it is such a strong message
what do you get out of that book well I
left home pretty much at the age of 13
and went to boarding school and I
haven't lived at home since then and
I've been independent for a long time it
forced me to grow up and then I've been
financially responsible for myself since
I was 18 so I grew up I feel like I grew
I had to grow up really quickly but and
one of the reasons that I've set up so
many adventures with my dad is because I
missed a lot of time with him between 13
and 18 all those holidays through 13 to
18 in those really influential years I
had a lot of time with a grandparent
with my grandfather my grandfather was
born in 1912 he was the Ducks I don't
know what you call it in America but he
was the brightest kid in his middle
school oh he's the valedictorian of his
middle school Bell Victoria of his
middle school and he was given a
scholarship to go away to a college
where they were a Catholic college in
Christ Church which was over the
mountains over the Southern Alps in New
Zealand for one reason or another he
wasn't given that opportunity and didn't
get to go to that school go to high
school and he became a bike mechanic in
his teens and very quickly put himself
through becoming becoming an a-grade
mechanic and then worked as a mechanic
up until he was about 65 and he was at
the same place for many many years but
my grandfather was unbelievably smart
and never got to fully realize his
potential academically but he used it he
used his intellect in other ways and I
spent a lot of hours with him in his
workshop where he was a gunsmith he
would fix guns he would bed guns he he
was absolutely meticulous had the most
incredible tools if he didn't have the
tool he'd make the tool this is a New
Zealand this is a New Zealand it not a
place known for guns well a lot of
people do have guns you know
but for hunting and my grandfather was a
sharpshooter actually a number of my
family members were sharpshooters in the
war but it was a quite a big sport in
New Zealand target shooting sure and and
and he got me into it at a very young
age and I made the New Zealand under 25
team when I was at 16 I think with him
being my coach but I spent a lot of
hours watching him and and target
shooting is all about focus and
discipline you have to be so meticulous
to be a good shooter dropping your heart
rate feeling you know connecting with
the rifle and really seeing clearly and
making sure you pull the trigger night
it's like there's so much involved in
such a mental sport anyway I spent so
much time with him and I learned so much
from him I think because of that and he
invented an outrigger sight his friend
went blind in his right eye and he was
on the New Zealand team he couldn't see
out of his right eye and my grandfather
had a dream that if he built an
outrigger sight if he moved the sight
the distance of the pupil between the
right eye and the left eye that this guy
Mars Callaghan could could look through
his left eye close his right eye look
through his left eye and then had this
outriggers sight that was off offset by
the distance of his pupil at the other
end of the barrel and he would be able
to see and shoot and sure enough at work
my grandfather got in the middle of the
night built it and that is hard to make
up yeah and now you can buy it off the
shelf my grandfather never patented it
but that was how his brain worked and so
I think because of that relationship I
have a tremendous amount of respect for
older people who have so much to give
and age discrimination to me is one of
the biggest crimes that we have where
there's such a focus on young and this
is the new thing and this is the new way
and we need young people and I'm all
about that because young is new and
different I'm all about that but I'm
also a firm believer that we are wasting
a tremendous amount of tremendous talent
pool of people in this country who could
share their wisdom and their life
knowledge with young people who maybe
have lost their way or where we tap into
that resource and
yeah it's it's sort of very sad to me
when I hear when I hear it and I see it
see it a lot of my business well we
don't want the the guy who's 60 who
wrote the script we want the 25 year old
kid he's got this great idea well yeah
sometimes that guy who's been writing
for 10,000 hours actually might be able
to offer you something yeah for sure
maybe we can learn from that guy you
mentioned the the marksmanship your you
also have a long history with cycling
mm-hmm and have done quite a lot on two
wheels could you tell us a little bit
about your latest documentary and what
I'd love for you to comment on is how
you chose this project and choose
projects in general because you have
many different options you can do many
different things so how do you choose
something like this to focus on and key
tell us a little bit about it you know I
think one of the reasons that this
project came about is I feel um I feel
I'm open to anything happening at any
moment I believe in magic I believe I
believe in not planning too much ahead
being receptive to what might come
tomorrow or who I might meet and being
open to the possibilities that come from
those meetings and books I read and so I
found this book at an airport it was a
tiny little book with some publisher
that I'd never heard of written by some
guys that I'd never heard of and it said
the first New Zealand er to ride in the
Tour de France 1928 seven-time New
Zealand champion Harry Watson from
Canterbury New Zealand I'm like hold on
a second I love cycling I love cycling
history how how do I not know who this
guy is I read the book in one sitting
and I know some professional cyclists I
emailed them and said you ever heard of
this guy Harry Watson they're like Harry
who seven times New Zealand champion so
I read the book and then I find out that
this guy Harry Watson used to go over to
Australian ride in these races with the
best riders in Australia and there was
only one guy over there who could beat
him and they would go back and forth
winning races but he would go over there
and take part in these amazing thousand
mile races
back to New Zealand not say a word to
anybody would never make it into the
press it would make it in the press it
he won like a new zoom championship but
nobody had any really real idea at the
caliber that this guy was riding it he
had records that stood for like 50 years
amazing and I just became so fascinated
with the idea that this guy was the
epitome of what we talk about when we
talk about an understated New Zealand er
like you don't talk about your
achievements you don't show off about
your achievements and like he was the
poppy that what he never actually grew
up to be chopped off he just went and
achieved things and just kept it all
really low no probe on a low profile so
I looked at it and I started doing some
research and this is with my wife and
I'm producer partner and the more we
research the more we realized the 1928
Tour de France had the first
english-speaking team that competed and
it was this one New Zealand er and three
Australians went six weeks at sea all
the way to France with one set of
rollers between them on these old heavy
steel bikes rocked up there to the start
line in Europe and the Europeans were
like what the hell are you doing here
where have you come from you guys do not
realize that we're the best riders in
the world the toughest sporting event on
earth you're going to come here and try
to school us who are you guys and they
were only four guys that were meant to
team up with six other riders to make a
team of 10 like all the big riders but
the other ride has been turn up the
sponsors fell through so now they're
over on the other side of the world four
against ten and 15 of the 22 stages were
team time trials but they refused to
give it press wrote him off everybody
wrote him off and they decided they were
going to race and it's not like you know
you can send out a tweet and say hey I'm
looking for some riders or you know call
up they just couldn't get it together so
for that this at the at the starting
line and the sad part of it all is that
this story has all been lost because
they're gone and started digging around
digging around and I thought you know
what the only way that this story needs
to be told because it's like these
unforgotten underdogs
the highest attrition rate in Tour de
France history 1928 was brutal I thought
the only way to really tell the story is
I need to find one of those old bikes
that they rode I need to find the old
route I need to find where they went
I need to go and ride it stick to the
same schedule and then juxtapose 2013 my
ride with their ride in 1928 match up
old photographs look for old footage and
tell this story so that it isn't
forgotten it was like not like it was
ever really known in New Zealand but
like that we tell the story what is the
name of the documentary
it's called low ride look I'd yell I'd
and and I made another film called the
ride not that could be confused with
that ride which was across America yeah
no I need to get more creative with the
names I think well you was that doing in
South America and ride see I had the
ride on my hat and I thought if I just
you know all I have to do is just change
you know one I just have to take out two
letters put an L there and boom I've got
the same hat ready to rock and roll so
how long was the course then 3338 miles
an average of 150 miles a day not flag
round did this was Bruegel single speed
bicycles marginal brakes bikes that
weigh twice as much as a modern bike
does today 130 mm vertical feet the
death stage by the time they'd got
through eight stages they went from 168
starting in Paris to 100 after eight
stages by the time they finished the
death stage of the ninth stage the
winning time in 1928 was eighteen and a
half hours it was two hundred and
something miles and over 20,000 vertical
feet in one day over five major climbs
in the Pyrenees that separates of Spain
and France eighteen and a half hours the
winning time what was really cool about
this story was this is 1928 this is ten
years after World War one
nothing has or has had more impact on
New Zealand than World War one ten
percent of the New Zealand population
went to Europe went to Gallipoli went to
all these places in Europe to fight
alongside mother England in World War
one ten percent
imagine that
chips they traveled to the other side of
the world to fight so everybody has lost
relatives or has a relative who fought
in the war so the French people
remembered the Anzacs the Australian and
New Zealand troops that had only been in
France ten years before fighting in the
trenches in northern France against the
Germans they remembered that sacrifice
so when the French people realized that
this small untested underdog team were
taking on the best riders in the world
and that they were going to ride around
France they got out on the streets and
they cheered this underdog team and they
not only won over the public they then
won over the French press and then they
won over the other riders and by the end
of the ride three out of those four
riders made it around France only forty
two riders out of a hundred and
sixty-eight riders made it they made it
with four against ten that's insane is
in world-class riders like these guys
were world cuspid that nobody knew if
you were to say that like if that was a
headline in New Zealand that they made
it people I mean I just don't think in
New Zealand people understand because
cycling is such a complicated sport I'm
not sure if they truly understand the
significance of how incredible that
achievement is and he's not in the
sporting Hall of Fame Harry Watson I
think he should be if he was in all
black it was a rugby player he would be
super Hubert Aukerman on the other hand
was knighted Sir Hubert Offerman he was
a politician he was instrumental in
getting in a Brid of the White Australia
Policy he was in this sketches for him
in Australia but in New Zealand this guy
who's from my hometown there's nothing
and I'm trying now to raise the money to
put a permanent fixture in Christchurch
over one of the cycle ways to for us
never to forget him but the film is
certainly helping where can people find
the film Phil Keoghan
la ride calm and and my name is a crazy
I'll put it in the show notes for people
so they can find yeah I can't even spell
my name sometimes so hard to spell so I
encourage people to check it out I
watched the trailer and just the very
beginning when you guys are riding on
these old rickety bikes across
cobblestones just getting started
not a good idea like a killing goodbye
day this is not a good idea by the way I
mean we yeah not a good idea try to try
to make a movie while you're taking on
the biggest physical and mental
challenge of your life not a good recipe
for making them that's just not a good
thing to do that dance stage I was
telling you about yeah took us 23 and a
half hours to finish boys we had seven
stages over 200 miles on those old bikes
with no gears his really jacked my hip
up for like about 15 months I had like
crazy pain in my hip I couldn't get rid
of it until I got a standing desk by the
way that's what fix ending desk I got a
standing desk
boom within three weeks all right so
let's talk about a few things like that
because before we start recording you
pulled up a microphone because we were
looking at my current audio setup which
is a zoom h6 with some basic expose away
thank you very simple why is Morgan
Spurlock put put it to me once you get
fancy fancy gets broken this is not
fancy I have a shure sm58 stage mics
here he's an interesting guy isn't he he
is an interesting I we were on Oprah
together once I was all right yeah I'm
backed on a trip 2001 that was the first
time I met him with 2001 we were both on
or Oprah yeah wow that's that's a hell
of a place to meet and you brought up a
microphone because you often have to do
pickups audio on the road a lot and it's
a sure md-88 digital stereo condenser
mic which plugs right into the Lightning
port on an iPhone recommended to me by
the guy who mixed the ride the the film
really talented guy he actually also
mixed hidden figures he's a passionate
cyclist and yeah I just I thought well
if this guy says it's good it's got to
be good and you tested it out I've I'm
always curious about travel mic options
because even with the amount of gear
that I have it weighs a lot to truck
around and carry around this stuff but
what other gear or tools are must-haves
for you when you're on the road there
any any particular maybe non-obvious
gizmos gadgets
ways of packing not packing anything
that comes to mind that that you found
is necessary for your survival on the
road when you're doing these twelve
episodes in 20 days like Nicole with
Death March but they mean intense travel
schedules yeah you know it's interesting
I get that question from people about
what to pack what to travel I am crazy
about technology like I love technology
so much my first job I mentioned was as
a film camera assistant I did and then
watching my grandfather's a gunsmith and
then being a camera assistant was great
because you had to be so meticulous
about looking after the gear I always
been enamored with what's the latest
greatest craze and what can you do with
technology a friend of mine says it's
great isn't it great living in the
future and I totally agree with them I
think it's so important to keep up with
the technology and just how you and I
are sharing oh this try this Mike this
is great and then I see your setup and
you know every you keep learning all the
time right you see how people do things
and how people pack and the cameraman
that I've been working with for 25 years
every time I see him he and I are big
repurposes yeah so we would like we love
finding the best ways to repurpose
things new ways of doing things and and
a big part of that is is in technology
that said I'm also old-school I also
have had a mole skin diary that I write
into that I've had for 30 years so I'm
kind of like when you see my the stuff
that I travel with I have like really
old-school you know paper and pencil and
then all the way through to the latest
technology so this film that we shot the
ride we shot was the first documentary
ever shot on a Sony f55 4k camera that
at that stage it never shot a feature
film
you know they equivalent of super 35
millimeter in digital right and and then
beautiful Algenol glasses glass and that
sort of thing I think you're crazy to
travel without some means of capturing
video or audio I am amazed of what
without mentioning a name but I'm amazed
at what a smartphone can do it blows my
mind I've you know the new phone that I
have has two lenses in it the audio
quality is extraordinary I just shot
this project for Smithsonian and 4k we
she doing it in UHD and there's a shot
that I needed and I was sitting
somewhere where there's no way I was
going to get a camera there in time or
in the space where I was and I pulled
out this cam this phone set it to 4k and
we cut it in as a quick cutaway shot on
my phone I love that yeah it is amazing
and I love that I can 5 o'clock in the
morning walk out in my dad's garden with
the this little microphone plug it into
my phone and be standing there
surrounded by all these birds and you
heard the quality no it's outrageous I
just love it so what would what would be
let's just say a purchase of less than
$100 if something comes to mind that is
most positively impacted your life in
recent memory less than $100 yeah
probably the biggest impact for
something less than $100 would be a
multiple Diary moleskin diary yeah I've
had I've got them all lined up from
every year since I've had him since 1986
so in there in a very tactile way movies
I have like listen the back movies books
and then I write in the back the name of
the book and then who recommended the
book and then I make a little note and
then I tick them off and then when I
read the book I write to the person who
recommended the book and they were like
I recommended that maybe yeah you did
and then I'll tell them where and when
and the index of books and movies in the
back of the diary in the back of the
diary and then every year if there's
something that I haven't read or found
in that year like sometimes some really
obscure things I'll transfer those over
into the next year but now moleskin has
this crazy pen that has a little camera
on it that records everything you write
digitally on paper and then you can
email like you and I could be talking
about some notes just like you're sure
book there and then I just tap the pen
on a little envelope icon and I can text
it email it post it whatever and it's
recorded on when you go back it's all
recorded back on your computer yeah
that's very cool I use a tool called
ever Evernote and sometimes penultimate
for similar purposes what do you write
in your journal in sense that do you sit
down at a set time do tend to every
night sit down
this diary what is not a diary guy like
that as much as more just ideas or
sketches I just came up with a new name
for something that I'm for a brand that
I'm wanting to explore developing I just
wrote down the name it was a sort of
free association and I arrived on this
name as like boom I love this name and
then I went and looked it up and it was
available and so then I you know did a
trademark on it and then I started
sketching with it so a lot of times is
just fleshing out ideas I also use it
for meetings that so every time I meet
with somebody I put the date I put the
time my mother taught shorthand I wish
I'd learned from her but I I write down
key elements of the meeting a lot of
times I can remember the pages so I'll
go that's right I met with ten when was
that oh yeah that was one and sixteen
and then I'll go back into the diary
again they're all chronological and I
can remember roughly or I'll just look
it up in the calendar that's the easy
way but a lot of the times I challenge
my brain aver yeah I was April and then
flick through to that part and look at
the notes that's what Robert Rodriguez
filmmaker director writer and so on also
does he he keeps copious notes
I love notes on meetings and then he
transfers them I think to a word doc at
roughly midnight and that way he's able
to go back and search which you could do
with some of these newer technique well
he would love this moleskin diary
because it's the same thing yeah but he
wouldn't have to double transfer because
right it converts it into automatically
converts it yeah let him know well he's
here in Austin Phil this has been great
fun where can people and of course I'll
put this in the show notes as well for
people listening but where can people
say hello to you on social or elsewhere
a lot of people contact me through
Twitter is just my name at Phil Keoghan
yeah you spell that for those people out
there who are spelling I really think
they're going to remember this okay
hi my listeners and bright people all
right so Phil it's the ordinary filled
ph IL and then Kogan which is k e o GH a
n and my website is just my name Phil
Keoghan comm and they can find you yeah
many people have a way of finding these
covers some way well Phil thank you so
much for the time I really appreciate
you yeah now it's great to be here yeah
I know you've talked to a lot of really
cool people and it's nice to be here
spend some time with you
likewise no I mean these are great
stories and everybody listening think
about 3 p.m. tomorrow
yeah that's your deathbed what are you
going to say I wish I had I wish I could
put together that list and also as
always you can find links to everything
we've talked about the new film and
where you can find film everything where
you can find film where you can find
film and Phil yeah and everyone Phil and
everything else
the old man see and so on in the show
notes at Tim blog forward slash podcast
you can also find every other episode
and until next time thank you for
listening hey guys this is Tim again
just a few more things before you take
off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me would you enjoy getting a short
email from me every Friday that provides
a little morsel of fun before the
weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest
things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
has somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it this
episode is brought to you by headspace
the world's most popular meditation app
I have it on my phone I use it all the
time when I'm in ubers when I'm in
airplanes when I'm in those in-between
spaces and I want to do some good for
myself across all of the guests that I
have learned podcast more than eighty
percent have the common behavior at the
common habit of some type of meditative
practice it does not have to be
complicated or expensive headspace is
meditation made simple I've used it for
hundreds of sessions myself it provides
guided meditations you can use whenever
you want wherever you want whether on
your phone computer or tablet
they have sessions that focus on
everything from decreasing stress and
anxiety to eating healthier sleeping
better and even being more creative but
I suggest you keep it simple simple
simple
this is a huge impact on my life try
there take ten program it is fantastic
ten minutes of guided meditation today
for 10 days it costs you nothing try it
out and I promise and I don't do this
very much that you will see a
significant benefit from it download the
headspace app and train your mind for a
happier healthier life learn more
headspace calm board / Tim that's
headspace calm forward / Tim this
episode is brought to you by me undies
which I'm wearing right now I've spent
the last year or so wearing underwear
from these guys nearly 24/7 except when
I'm having panic them and they are the
most comfortable and colorful underwear
I have ever owned if you can imagine
that really awesome graffiti that you've
seen in cities like LA or elsewhere then
turn into a print and put onto underwear
you get the idea
there's also some weird stuff like
Halloween themed camo which I have for
myself
Neely's designed in LA and made from
sustainably sourced micro mowed ow why
is it important it's three times softer
than cotton and you feel that difference
on your loins ladies and gentlemen if
they feel and go to eight and if you
don't love your first pair of me undies
they'll hook you up with a new pair or a
refund what kind of person sends in used
underwear back to someone I don't know
that makes you a strange person maybe
you should sell them in Japan or
something but if you love the product
and they make a great gift also and for
those people wondering I go boxer-briefs
if you love it they have a subscription
offer or you can save up to 33% after
your first pair so check it out the
undies dot-com forward slash Tim you can
see some of my favorite underwear and
also plenty for the ladies that's me
undies comm forward slash Tim
you
[Applause]